[Musica]
la vita sono io non mi riconosci
tagli che
[Musica]
se nessuno
mi è sembrato di sentire qualcosa qua in
camera che cosa ci fa il mio libro
aperto qua
qualcuno ha preso è aperto il mio libro
forse è stato solo vitale vitale
è mai stato tu ad aprire il mio libro e
lasciarlo qua sul commotivo aperto
apriva il tuo libro
qualcuno l'ha aperto qualcuno l'ha letto
no non sono stato io
[Musica]
ma no saranno gli uccelli
[Risate]
c'è qualcos'altro ma io sono un amico di
marino berlino è un suo amico che è
entrato dentro casa o sei forse giù che
stavi annusando
non è un amico di berlino mi sa di no
[Musica]
logo
questo
è dietro questo bordo basso
ci sono dei graffi degli ululati credo
che ci sia un lungo dentro
pensa un po io pensavo fossero i tubi
dell'acqua che non andavano bene
enormi dell'alba
al mio tre abbiamo la porta vediamo dice
qua dentro che 12
tu chi
è la testa ma non avete visto un lupo
andare in bagno
piacere potete di gentilmente
sono ideali che aspetto questo momento
finalmente
ora in un momento per me grazie se non
mi dispiace cosa
quel lupo immagino
suggerimento
favore
si scusa noi non volevamo disturbarti
solo che questa in teoria sarebbe casa
nostra e costa il nostro bagno e da dove
è uscito
insomma dove un momento ottimo compagno
così vi abbiamo
ma che cosa io meno successo non mi ha
capito
chi era quello lo avete visto un lupo
sul gabinetto sicuramente ha qualcosa a
che fare col libro perché sapete che nel
mio libro ci sono anche i lupi i lupi
mannari
forse la risposta è proprio nel mio
libro a proposito lo avete già preso è
disponibile in tutte le librerie e su
amazon
se non l'avete ancora preso storie
paurose a scuola di misteri andate
subito a prenderlo non potete non averlo
stories family e ora cerchiamo una
soluzione con il libro forse in una
delle schede creatura cima idea
finito speriamo che si lavi le mani poi
dopo le
zampe avete un lupo
scusate
ma
chi sei tu e ragazzi e astra è lunga
adesso vi spiego tutto io sono l'ex lupo
l'ex mag dopo l apostrofo ex o l'ex
tutto unito no non l'ex nel senso che
era un lupo perché come vedi io sono
mezzo lupo e mezzo umano quindi non è
l'ex l apostrofo ex è l'ex tutt
attaccato il mio nome che come centri
con il mio libro storie paurose ecco
vedi quel libro è un oggetto o
straordinario da lì sono uscite molte
creature anche lì io sono uscito da te
sei uscito da questo libro come hai
fatto e è un po complicato da spiegare e
praticamente
in quel libro io sono stato catturato e
anche altri altre creature sono state
catturate lì dentro con me stavamo
insieme e adesso qualcuno mi ha liberato
come potete immaginare non hanno
liberato solo me ma anche altre creature
quindi le altre creature che sono in
questo libro sono state liberate
esatto voi sapete che creature sono in
questo libro vero ma aspetta un momento
tu sei un lupo buono quindi si si
considera un tuo alleato un tuo amico ok
è un po strano
wow un mezzo lupo a fluido è puro nostro
alleato e adesso cosa dovremmo fare noi
quello che dovete fare è cercare le
creature e catturarli in modo da
completare le schede creature del libro
completare le schede creatore degli
artisti perché sapete che nel mio libro
fiori paurosa ci sono le schede creature
con tutte le informazioni delle creature
spetta fahmy controllare non c'è più
l'illustrazione della creatura non c'è
più quindi dobbiamo catturarla dentro al
libro ma come facciamo a ritrovare le
creature scappate dal libro esattamente
come avete fatto a trovare me immagino
che vi abbia portato il libro il libro
mi condurrà dalle altre creature ho
capito ti ricordi che il libro ci tirava
e ci stava tirando verso la porta e
quindi sarà il libro condursi dalla
creature ma oppure no non mi conduce da
nessuna parte il libro però però non
tenerlo così vicino a me per meno voluto
aprirlo come vicino sono catture di
stime ho capito tu stai uscito dal libro
quindi potrei ricattura rete e destro al
libro sì ma questo non deve succedere
sono un po troppo aiutarvi hai ragione
allora dobbiamo iniziare la nostra
ricerca delle altre creature il più
presto possibile se non calcoliamo le
creditori beh se le lasciamo va in giro
libere cosa potrebbe succedere potrebbe
succedere per esempio che un bambino
potrebbe mordere e tante altre persone e
poi tutte queste persone insieme tutti
questi bambini insieme si
trasformerebbero sarebbe molto
complicato poi ti creerebbe un esercito
di vampiri
esattamente non possiamo fare in modo
che questo succeda vedono iniziamo a
cercare il libro non mi sta dando nessun
segnale ancora
[Musica]
bene e
credo che sia un po umano un po'come e
cioè il lupo ma anche in gomma
beh forse è meglio se lo lasciamo
tranquillo guardare gli uccellini eh si
sembra ti piaccia tanto osservarle ma
perché io non si è accorto di niente e
il signor l'ex lupo si sai che noi
abbiamo un cane che dorme o meglio
esemplare
ciao piccolo
noi siamo quasi colleghi siamo quasi
colleghi gli amici a quattro zampe
ciao papà lo sapevo noi diventeremo
tanto amici berlino è felicissimo
sì adesso vi riconoscerà per sempre
proprio contento era un amico beppe lupo
ma
insieme siamo a me al
libro ci sta portando verso di la testa
seguite
ma sei sicuro anita ma sei sicura che
dobbiamo andare lassù è un po buio il
libro si sta quotando la sua dobbiamo
catturare la creatura qualsiasi creatura
essa sia non possiamo lasciarla libera
qua
ei bastard deboli spiega di mimo nei
tubi di suu kyi qualcosa da sopra magari
posso venire con me ma sto arrivando
creatura
dove sei
se si può una nuda sta soffrendo di
capire dove potrebbero ma pensa che
stiamo nel posto giusto
però non mi dice dove esattamente
seguire i suoni i rumori si ottima idea
da dove veniva ma soprattutto che
creatura sarà tra le mie creature del
libro controlliamo
dietro al divano sotto i cuscini e una
panatura se nessuno andava dentro
così a farsi creatura
no non c'è la creatura qui non c'è
niente
paura
tendo di no
perchè prima
dobbiamo cercare la creatura io prego
con un freddo molto
legati forse può servirci a vestire
giocando
qualcosa cercando
di servirà per trovare la rete delle ri
fronte della costruzione funzioni per il
foggia che bella questa
io prendo questa io prendo festa che non
funziona
non sembra niente questo senso che
questa
questo sicuramente quello si nasconderà
dietro la creatura sarà unanime creatura
forse è il fantasma dell'opera che si
nasconde davvero
non c'è niente un teatrino è
effettivamente un cellino fa tenere i
tuoi libro magari a temi che era la
strada giusta
ottima idea ti affido la lampadina che
non funziona
è una torcia una torcia che non
funzionava allora ok libro ti puoi
guidare le creature
ieri
ci sono due porte su quelle porte
andiamo
[Applauso]
tale
limite è buttato sul divano penso ho
portato io e chi proprio qui sotto ci
dando ad esso che visto un pò il
perimetro della stanza
potresti impiegarmi dove la creatura
sembra di sì ho incollato qui su questa
porta è pronto sì andiamo a scoprire che
cosa c'era dietro 3 2 1
ok
ma
continuano voi qualche problema meno in
questa casa ancora giù a mare stavamo
cercando la creatura che ci fai tu qui
di nuovo in bagno dopo tutto questo
tempo ho bisogno di andare al bagno per
le troppe se n'è anche un'altra
invenzione ma cosa state aspettando
andate a cercare la creatura lasciatemi
in pace è il libro che ci ha condotto
qua da te perché tu sei una creatura è
quindi ci porta da te ma stiamo cercando
l'altra creatura diciamo io avvio
prima dove dobbiamo andare
va bene va bene ti lasciamo imparato
speriamo se dobbiamo trovare questa
creatura si batte
e lui giu io vado a controllare se
merlino bisogno del mio aiuto
forse berlino trovato la creatura
che provo
stavo andando verso qualcosa
[Musica]
era tutto il tempo con occhi in questa
porta la creatura non in quell'altra
porta ora non c'è vitale però ma vabbè
però vuol vedere se riesco io a
catturare la creatura con il libro
vediamo innanzitutto che creatura è
pronti
[Musica]
ehi
creatura
dove sei
chi sei che cosa sei che creatura 6
vitale si l'ex torino avete presente la
creatura che stavo cercando sa piano di
sopra
sì c'è un problema che problema
l'ho trovata ma mi ha morso il lupo
proprio e il lupo che cosa succederà
adesso
no no non ci siamo non ci siamo non va
beh quindi che cosa posso fare adesso se
vuoi sapere cosa succederà apre il libro
e il reggino la scheda creatura ma si
trasformerà il lupo mannaro che ora cosa
facevamo o scappiamo anche perché
diventa pericolosa ma si dovesse in una
soluzione no tu che abbiamo non lo
saprai qual è la soluzione se non voto
per fermarla questa trasformazione
credo che sia un pò tardi adesso l'unico
dove catturare la creatura che ti ha
fatto questo sono scappata non ho fatto
in tempo a catturarla e allora cosa
faccio non voglio trasformarmi ormai è
troppo tardi ti dobbiamo rinchiudere
vitale dobbiamo rinchiuderla
rinchiudervi da qui qui e noi andiamo
via se passerà questa notte domani non
ci sarà più un problema
ma stanotte tu sei pericolosissima sarei
piena di pelè avrai le foci così non va
bene dobbiamo scappare noi vitale
dobbiamo scappare andiamo e veroli dai
che abbia ragione potresti essere molto
pericolosa potresti potreste addirittura
mangiarvi quindi forse è meglio se ci
chiudiamo qui resti tranquilla
tranquilla solo per questa notte poi da
domani già sarà tutto diverso va bene
domani ma mirati vento ad aprile sono
tutti se lo sarebbe se trasformarmi per
non farmi trasformare le un lupo saprà
come si fanno e come detto il 6 stata
morsa al 11 cura la scala che matura e
domani mattina hanno attinto molto e
non credo che mi trasformerò dai paesi
che scrivo delle liste rete le passò
sotto la porta che sia giunta è targa
dai cerchi un'altra soluzione libro
magari c'è un'altra
non c'è che dire
l'elezione che la san nicoletto perché
ne pensi non c'è un'altra escursione no
no no no a scagionarlo specie così è
quello
dovrei mandare sono un po preoccupato
per metro xvi che domani si sentirà
meglio forse dovrei stare più tranquillo
e sicuro tutto anni e sarà abbassato
tutto speriamo non essere intelligenti
di solito lo so che non si riduca una
romana facevano passare solo questa
notte
ma io non mi grazie però al lupo mannaro
non mi sento gruppo mandarmi 0
eppure io mi sento benissimo
anzi non credo proprio che mi
trasformerò è
diversa questa volta forse con la
creatura non era un lupo magari era
qualcosa altro magari era solo un cane e
quindi non mi trasformerò il lupo
mannaro
devo dirglielo subito vabbè lasciamo
perdere hanno troppa paura anche l'ex ha
paura eppure lui e mezzo gruppo mezzo
umano non dovrebbe avere paura di un
lupo mannaro no vorrà dire che aspetterò
qua aspettiamo questa trasformazione che
secondo me non succederà e secondo voi
se non avete ancora lasciate un mi piace
mi raccomando lasciate un mi piace qui
sotto che cosa potrei fare nel frattempo
ha ovviamente leggiamo il mio libro
e voi ce l'avete è disponibile in tutte
le librerie e su amazon non riuscirete a
smettere di leggerlo storie paurose con
due ragazzini e due ragazzine come
protagonisti compagni di classe amici
per la pelle un certo punto però arriva
una nuova insegnante una supplente che è
un po paurosa particolare e assegna loro
il compito di fare delle ricerche su
alcune creature tra cui i lupi mannari e
vampiri e poi non vi spoiler o altro con
ogni storia che finirete di leggere
accumulerete dei punti il coraggio e
alla fine del libro in base a quanti
punti avete accumulato potrete scoprire
a quale profilo appartenete è bellissimo
anche se non vi piace leggere o non vi
piace tanto a leggere o vi annoia questo
libro non vi annoierà per niente anzi vi
terrà col fiato sospeso fino alla fine
quindi se non se lo avete ancora andati
a prenderle nel frattempo che aspetto
leggo un po
adesso come ti dicevo si trasformerà in
un lupo mannaro e succede esattamente
quando il primo raggio di luna la
colpirà quindi manca poco e già buio
pesto là fuori e per dire di sì
questione di attimi anzi senti senti è
così ex vieni avvicinati anche tu
sentire io non ho bisogno io ci sento
benissimo guarda che orecchie che ho
sono 12 m effettivamente non fa una
piega
[Musica]
l'ex una cosa mostruosa questa sì sto
trasformando
abbiamo fatto bene e chiudono in camera
mi avrebbe sbranato
abbiamo fermato completamente sarebbe
diventata così alta che avrebbe fatto in
123 bocconi forse al massimo quindi
adesso aspettiamo fino a domani mattina
esattamente dove mattina vita tornerà
normale speriamo bene ma non sento più i
rumori in effetti anche io con il mio
super unito non sento più niente che
cosa sarà successo
qui c'è davvero qualcosa di strano se
non dare a controllare pure si abbandona
non farlo devo rinnovato molto farlo ma
guarda che è intelligente lupo mannaro
forse questa è una trappola sai che ti
potrebbe sperare però io mi sto
preoccupando per anita ma non lo so è
inciampata si è fatta del male svenuta
devo avere controllare puoi andare al
premier greco ci metterà in pericolo io
lo so finiremo benissimo finiva mai tu
sei un lupo mettere mano solo
controllare se tua piccola forte io sono
il primo a scappare ok va bene allora
troviamo un compromesso uscirò solo io
andrò a controllare e tu rimarrai qui al
sicuro con la porta chiusa che è così se
sbrana sbrana solo me è molto pericoloso
lo dico per te credimi non ti
preoccupare e soprattutto nella stessa e
soprattutto una scolarità questa però
non è anita non è una meta che conosci
tu e così alta è piena di minuti non è a
vita e famelica capisci è un pericolo e
va bene sono pronto ad assumermi questo
pericolo ci penserò io tu non ti
preoccupare rumeni quali non me ne
occupo io va bene sono sicuro che edita
non mi farà del male stai tranquillo
grazie comunque per i consigli io me ne
vado
ci vediamo fra poco si resta qua puoi
dire che non ci aveva avvisato ormai
come berlino
lì da anita tutto bene sul tetto non c'è
nemmeno sul lampadario magari a sotto al
letto
anita dove sei magari qua sopra anita
ha lasciato il libro qua a limita si è
trasformata il lupo mannaro ha lasciato
il libero e non c'è più
[Musica]
uno è scappato dalla finestra qualità
questo è un disastro carità trasformato
il lupo mannaro e là fuori e
pericolosissima che posso lasciarla
libera così da sola può svelare qualcuno
può trovare qualcuno deve uscire subito
la devo cercare la devo trovare e
soprattutto la devo fermare non posso
permettere che è morta qualcun altro che
trasformi qualcun altro in un lupo
mannaro
portato il libro così almeno mi guiderà
da anita
sta funzionando
godiamoci lo spettacolo
[Risate]
manica manita dove sei sono venuto a
salvarti
la
vita
radiosei nascosta allora il punto della
situazione in questo momento è questo
lui crede veramente di non trovarla ma
lei l'ha già visto la già contatto non
andrà a finire tanto bene
l'ho trovata eccola lì
aveva ragione l'ex è diventata gigante e
anche pelosissimo
sanità sono io non mi riconosci
campo
è bellissimo lo sapevo ci voleva un po
di cose che volevo giocarmi la mia
[Musica]
che carini
adoro queste scene romantiche
adesso però il vero non è vero sai io ti
ha profetizzato è visto cosa è successo
se la si è vista proprio brutta
io mi sono divertito
stavo per prendermi e una a mordere
sì l'ho visto io ho visto tutto ho visto
tutto da qui scene romantiche come tu
sei stato veramente veramente bravo non
c'è cosa stai dicendo ho rischiato
tantissimo si vitale te l'avevo detto
ma è mai chiuso la porta a chiave
la chiave non hai chiuso la porta a
chiave il problema
non è che non ho chiuso la porta a
chiave non ho chiuso la porta non è
chiusa neanche la porta ma cosa ti dice
cervello e stavo scappando di fretta
turimo mannaro è un lupo mannaro non è
anita europeo naro e ci mangia e se vado
a chiuderla adesso non lo so adesso
proviamo proviamo magari già dentro e
moriamo volare dal detto dobbiamo volare
capisci dobbiamo scappare dobbiamo
scappare si svolgerà questa cosa ma
fermo no mi ricordo sono chiusa la porta
ma credo di no
chiudiamo questa porta magari non arriva
qui
moriremo tutta la chiave
siamo salvi borsa
[Musica]
buongiorno come va
buongiorno cosa dormi bene
insomma mica mica così tanto bene e tu
come dormito io benissimo
ciao berlino tu che ci fai qui chi da
fate voi qui perché stava dormendo tutti
qua non ci ricordi quello che è successo
ieri ma stai scherzando
non mi dite che cosa è successo
l'ex ea sognando tutte lo ricordi vero
certo che me lo ricordo tu ti sei
trasformata in un lupo mannaro e
gigantesche ri così grande non puoi
crederci ma perché ci avevi tutti belli
più di me guarda un bordo guardare chi
guarda e di questi ben ditto cine devi
così non sa di cosa state parlando
fatevi dormire un po mi sento un po
stanca in effetti mi sento come se non
avessi dormito tutta la notte
ciao berlino
ma che fai questo non è il momento di
dormire unità sveglia sveglia forza
ma guarda che tu ieri era un lupo
mannaro e succederà di nuovo ne sono
sicuro è mero mezzo no non mi
trasformerai di nuovo il lupo mannaro
man deve più succedere questo non deve
più sentiamo lanciamo adesso devi
assolutamente catturare il lupo deve
assolutamente catturarlo il libro ci
vuole libro eccolo ok allora leggi metti
la scheda creatura
aspetta aspetta ecco la scheda creatura
in effetti sì mi ricorda qualcosa il
libro così l'ingresso evan roth le
stelle creatura dobbiamo catturare il
boss è però non mi ricorda di essere
diventata un lupo mannaro vabbè comunque
dai speriamo se diamo sempre il lupo
allora presto presto l'unica soluzione è
catturare il lupo a tradate aggravate
abbiamo allora prendiamo catturare il
lupo in bocca al lupo
che avessimo avuto andiamo dai sbrigati
aspetta un momento però nella scheda
creatura c'era scritto il punto debole
del boom mannaro el'argento dobbiamo
prima attrezzarci con qualcosa di
argento e altrimenti ci sbraneranno è ci
porterà nuovamente come va ha morso me
potresti diventare anche tu non daro
presto cerchiamo qualcosa d'argento no
no no io non voglio diventare lupo
mannaro
cosa possiamo trovare d argento non lo
so pensiamoci per appendere l'argento
formale anche a me quindi io devo fare
qua chiesto qua ho cambiato rimani quale
ok ok andremo noi andremo noi sì se si
bagna cerchiamo qualcuno ci vorranno ci
avevo pensato di cucina porta in bocca
al lupo non lo sapete in bocca quali
lupo
[Risate]
abbiamo
con voi questi sono d'argento di metallo
nero leginio mordono verdetto
probabilmente sì c'è qualcosa d'argento
però non c'è tempo da perdere ci
dobbiamo preparare adesso vediamo se
però potrebbe essere
questo lo usi come scudo mette così però
sono chiudo questo qui non è detto però
sicuramente di aiutare nel caso in cui
nel caso in cui un e volesse con rate in
testa il distretto pulito piccola cosa
sbagliato potrete fa bene a competere a
un vero lupo sì qualcosa d argento ci
sarà lo prenderemo no secondo voi ci
riusciremo a prendere il lupo a
catturare il lupo delle libero che vede
il libro
il libro non libri tutu dovevo prendere
io metto un momento è rimasto in camera
facciamo prenderlo ma si incamera
connesso
c'è un problema ci siamo divertiti un
momento e devo togliere questo
scolapasta dalla testa e allora e
abbiamo preso le cose d'argento ma non
ti preoccupare non ci avvicineremo a te
per non farti del male ma piuttosto
attenta state attenti con quelle cose lì
potete farmi del male lo sapete potete
farmi male
brilla troppo l'argento brilla brilla
troppo non avvicinatevi comunque no no
guarda li accusiamo subito 466 pezzo
così volare siamo solo tornati perché è
come dire mi sono dimenticato il libro e
avremo bisogno del libro per prendere la
creatura giusto
se no come facciamo a trovare il lupo è
soprattutto a catturarlo
messo qui era qua mi sembra forse no
forse lo avevo appoggiato qua non c'è
qua ed extra cavolo hai visto il libro
il libro libro fetta quale libro di
quale libro stiamo parlando qual è come
ricordare
come quelli libro il mio libro storie
paurose quelli propriamente le schede
creature hai visto quello qualche parte
non lasciato guà incamerato ci sembra un
po strano un po smemorato forza
l'ex ci stai forse nascondendo qualcosa
è impossibile che ti sei dimenticato del
libro il libro il vostro libro spettiva
[Applauso]
libro tu non ti potevi neanche
avvicinato il libro
ne avete smascherato
il libro l'ho preso io e non valori da
roma questo è l'unico modo per essere
sicuro di non cadere di nuovo qui dentro
è troppo prezioso è troppo potente anche
per sbaglio voi mi potreste ricatturare
questo non deve succedere non si vuole
aiutare davvero allora l'ex non è buono
come pensavamo e cattivo in realtà la
trovo le più a ridarci il libro qui non
si tratta più di amicizia tra lupo o
lupo
prendi v
vediamo cosa
[Applauso]
ci siamo nascosti qua sotto l'ex città
cercato non lo siamo nascosti b lo
abbiamo notato da letto
il libro non so come fare da interista
lo farei scudi ci fa riscoprire se fai
ancora rumorosi tu che stai facendo
rumore velo corto è arrivato merlino
farci 90 lui ci porterà con il suo fiuto
da cave
tommasino fai la guardia e avvisa ci si
arriva nextel lupo che
il libro ora disponibile in tutte le
librerie sono quindi potremo andare
ibridi a prenderne un'altra cosa io
tremo catturare le cose il lupo è anche
le altre creature haifa spetta se amiamo
libreria dobbiamo lasciare a berlino da
solo qui con le creature con l'ex no non
bastiamo noi lasciarlo qua da solo ma
non arriverebbe subito quindi non
possiamo prenderlo suonava tanto amiamo
per forza devo per forza riprendere
quella coppia di pallina rossi ma voi
l'avete preso invece avete preso il
libro storie paura se non l'avete ancora
presa e ora disponibile in tutte le
librerie online non mi raccomando però
ei
vegetali
giochiamo vi siete il nostro di adesso
io mi trovo adesso lo trovo quindi dice
nascosti e di voler giocare quando vi
troverò io vi morte
mirino vi voglio aiutare tu quindi per
favore dove sono anni di vitale
non mi vuoi aiutare
il trono tranquillo vengono abitativo
tranquillo perché no no no no no ma come
se niente
fosse bene vi troverò io li monder o
sta cercando di convincere berlino
attiri dove si lavora tutti a berlino
bravissimo di ranieri che ci proteggerà
e tu come potrei farla a berlino si
stanno avviando non a mandare via
l'extra il lupo perché ha capito che è
cattivo sì penso che dobbiamo
approfittarne di questo momento e salire
sopra nascondersi e per usi nervina ci
sta coprendo le spalle scopriamo adesso
tanto vi il lupo non farò mai del male a
merlino perché è un cane come stai
tranquillo va bene
come sempre vivono questo cane non vuole
aiutare berlino non è collaborativo
eppure pensavo fossi amici sa io ti
voglio bene ma tu almeno mi vuoi così
bene
presto presto presto gran se non ci sarà
aggiungiamo della musica studiando se
non magari primario mi sta arrivando st
rivaldo l'ex il lupo dobbiamo trovare un
nascondiglio subito dopo averlo proprio
folle idea che mettiamo delle trappole
come lui crederà che siamo nascosti qua
in camera ma in realtà siamo nascosti a
un'altra porta e scegliamo un altro
nascondiglio così lui perderà tempo e
noi voteremo trovare un nascondiglio
migliore l'importante è che riprendiamo
il libro così potremmo farlo al lupo
sino a un'idea prenderò le mie pantofole
che belle vedo troppo capire se il times
mai da dove partì
così mette al contrario ecco fatto e di
lui ora crederò questo non ha problemi a
troll a terra io invece ho lasciato qui
una manica di fuori così penserà che
sono nascosto ha detto proverà a
cercarvi che abbiamo adesso però ben da
un'idea
così potremo dire di poco dai testa
l'idea chi tra steli tirassimo tutti i
pupazzi interna saranno indoor dirlo
magari riuscirebbe a stordirlo e
riusciremo poi a rubargli il libro oggi
posso tirare anche l'aeroplano
[Musica]
sentirò questo l'anno viene bastano i
pupazzi
dove siete a mi capitava dove siete
volete giocare moniti gioca ci sta
cercato
ne ho trovati
[Musica]
nessuno
vuol dire dove siamo
numero di norme timbro
non vuoi collaborare ma bene va bene va
bene allora la città insieme sopra
eletto
dai venite fuori
io voglio soltanto morte e giocare con
voi
è caduto non abbia troppi
furbi sono proprio furbi sanno prendere
il libro forse dobbiamo iniziare ad
attaccarlo con i bubba altresì altre lo
attacchiamo
una
[Musica]
festa che ci sono
17 rialzato e dobbiamo tirare qualcosa
d'argento
poverino certo certo certo ma ci
riproveremo e così il libro ma presto
dobbiamo subito andare a catturare
l'altro lupo sia un po ci occuperemo di
lex ma tanto mi sembra che berlino lo
spazio nel tuo papà presto facciamoci a
guidare verso il lupo si
carino quella guardia ala guardia mex
presso qua per te
e dietro questa siepe controlliamo
dietro
allontanati affidamento
vogliamo solo
fare
freddo si è compattato catturato madrid
si mangia
abbiamo catturato il lupo ora manchi
solo tu non torni domani libro no vi
prego vi prego fate lo dobbiamo per
forza catturarti pensavamo fatti
buonanno fine ci hai tradito rubandoci
libro io non volevo io non volevo solo
che avevo paura di tornare in quel libro
ho fatto tutto per questo non ti credo
al mio tre aprire il libro e tornerai
dentro al libro
per favore per favore ti prego vi
scongiuro di 29 siete vi bravi ragazzi
per piacere possiamo ancora essere amici
anzi facciamo buti facciamo un patto
siete pronti facciamo un patto secondo
cui dovremo fidarsi di lei se poi mi
lasciate libero io vi aiuterò a provare
un'altra creatura beh in effetti
potrebbe esserci utile altrimenti come
facciamo da affrontare da soli ci
servirebbero dei consigli anche se
abbiamo già le schede creatura nel roidi
non ci serve troppo tuo aiuto perché
abbiamo le schede prelatura dai per
favore per favore fatelo per me ma non
solo vi aiuterò con la scrittura ma ogni
volta che avrete bisogno potete
chiamarmi e io verrò da voi ad aiutarvi
ora vi spiego come
potrebbe essere tragico finale lento e
allora per potermi chiare dovete bussare
nel libro tre volte e poi fare e
così io arrivano da voi oppure ma questo
solo se sarete veramente in pericolo ma
veramente in pericolo dovete fare così
a me sembra che ci stia preme leggero
quindi sto dicendo che se siamo in reale
pericolo ci basterà solo un l'area ok
non ci credete provate a fare quello
scatto l'ha detto guarda ok prova questo
spesso come la borsa tra le altre volte
123 entrando e abbaia
però tutto da dove apparso magico libro
magico
sembra di sì
quindi forse è va bene mi sembra che ti
sei pentito di quello che hai fatto è
che l'hai fatto solamente perché avevi
paura di essere rinchiuso nel libro
quindi siccome ci darà il tuo aiuto ogni
volta che lo vorremmo affare fatto
benissimo benissimo saremo un grande
team insieme ok ma vi raccomando non
tradirci più provetto progetto non
succederà mai più non ne sono pentito
davvero aspettavo ma non ho controllato
se è apparsa la scheda creatura
controlla vediamo allontanati ci si
sommano la scheda creatura è completa
quale sarà la prossima creatura attenti
la prossima creatura è molto molto molto
più pericolosa del lupo mannaro che
avete sfidato adesso ma sapete io avrei
da fare chiamatemi se avete bisogno di
aiuto ok ciao ciao ciao e mi raccomando
lasciate un mi piace per vedere il
prossimo episodio di storie paurose e se
non avete ancora preso il libro è ora
disponibile in tutte le librerie online
non potete non averlo all'interno
troverete già tutte le schede creatura
cliccate nel link in descrizione per
prender
[Musica]
che succede c'è qualcuno ei
questo che cos'è un po ul è comparso
guida niente vediamo cosa c'è dentro
pesa tantissimo
apriamo subito
aspetta forse non è una buona idea vi
ricordate quella volta che ho perso
quella scatola la scatola del primo ma
che succede c'è qualcosa di strano
c'è qualcosa dentro nessuno ce niente
devo subito prima
a un lucchetto
non si può offrire devo trovare la
chiave allora provo a chiedere evitare
magari lui l'ha vista da qualche parte
vitale
berlino circe avete vista la chiave da
qualche parte di questo baule ci metti
un sacco di tempo ad arrivare ogni volta
ottavi mangiando vero no che cosa sono
fa pensare ad aiuto aiuto che hai dato e
uscito fuori questo che cos'è la sopra è
comparsa la sopra aspetta ora ti spiego
che stavo leggendo il libro delle sue
cose a proposito l'avete preso era
disponibile in libreria online non
potete non averlo comunque stavo
leggendo il libro è un certo punto ha
iniziato trovare qualcosa
poi è comparso questo c'è solo un
problema però quello è il problema
guardavo un lucchetto
dobbiamo centrarle loro
potrebbe esserci qualcosa di malefico
poi centro che dobbiamo catturare con il
libro
magari quali pupazzi berlino aiutati a
cercar presto ci
hanno queste circa
sopra visto che il comparto qui il baule
voi perché il nostro è qualcosa li sto
controllando va beh nel frattempo di
questa ragazzi la scelta si basa passa
li sistemo io ma non c'è nessuno a
chiave allora no qui non sembra ci siano
chiavi
preso all idea proviamo a chiedere a
berlino eccesso e si stanno come si apre
questa scatola ma se c'è qualche rimane
del vero berlino aiutaci ci facciamo
prima subito apprezzato che ci sia
qualcosa di pericoloso qua dentro
dobbiamo cadere locali europei berlino
sembra addormentato guarda ci sta
provando ad aprirla forse funzionerà di
farcene sta applicando usa le tue unghie
per la pedina quell'oggetto vedi che si
riesce quasi ad aprile c'è qualcosa
dentro proprio vedere vedremo a capire
da quasi si vede qualcosa mai riuscito a
vedere qualcosa qua dentro cosa che non
riesco ad aprirla
dobbiamo trovare il modo di aprirla
potrebbe essere la chiave
si sentono dei suoni
ti senti
qualcuno qua dettori troppo stretto
questo spazio c'è qualcosa che vuole
uscire qua dentro non è un siero stupido
o piano piano piano ho idea se lo sbatte
stima terra
perché non ci vedeva proviamoci no
aspetta se ci fosse qualcosa di facile
guarda dentro si romperebbe
effettivamente sì forse è meglio andare
cauti
secondo voi cosa c'è qua dentro ma
soprattutto come facciamo a rapirlo set
dove troviamo la chiave secondo voi dove
potrebbe essere dobbiamo vedere favario
ma che va dai 30 ai ancora non sono mai
visto che luce lui all'interno dove
troviamo in genere le risposte
[Musica]
sul tema che sfida creatura ma si gira
come aprirlo si libero da jabri
no questa scheda crotone non riesco a
trovare la scheda creatura del baule beh
in effetti il baule non è un ambiente
naturale è un pezzo di rendere
effettivamente fatti anche abbastanza
sordo ciechi massimo l'ex per aiutarci
vi ricordate l'ex ci ho detto che
sarebbe arrivato il nostro aiuto ogni
volta che lo volessimo ottima idea
invece se chiamiamo un fabbro maury
fabbro riesce ad aprirlo fa abbiamo
paura di legno c'è anche del ferro qui
magari riuscirà ad aprirlo non potevamo
provare noi ad aprirlo con un cacciavite
o qualcosa ma no ci vuole il calcio
lucchetto non il cacciavite c'è il
lucchetto miglior novità nel frattempo
che vitale cerca un cacciavite qualcosa
io proprio forzarlo
dopotutto si possono scassinare i
lucchetti noti solo dei pirati
e come ho preso cacciavite allora ok
bravo noi proviamo portarlo prova
davvero quello che ha e forse si era
unito qui
perché quell urlo proveniva da qua e poi
se anche attivata per i credo che ci sia
qualcosa qua dentro o qualcuno aspettava
riproviamo proviamo ti do un bel colpo
di martello qui
ma
non possiamo portarlo ok è stata paura
che se lo portiamo qualsiasi cosa ci sia
può dentro si arrabbierà tanti questa
cosa o dall'originale continuare aspetta
aspetta primo così
è arrivato
e ascolta sono vitale se sei con il
genio della lampada mib mostra un po di
cibo per favore
nicolò magari genio è qui nostri
desideri non toccarlo più ha detto
quando che ha parlato con me quindi
sfida di genio tomba quando altro
potrebbe esserci la prossima creatura
del libro che il genio del baule stanno
facendo molto e quando uscirà da qui
alla fine per noi se hai ragione come
possiamo fare allora liberarlo il genio
sicuramente non dobbiamo farlo
arrabbiare ok questa è l'ultima cosa che
dobbiamo fare così quando abbiamo aperto
la scatola del terrore voi che lo
ricordiamo successivamente uscivano
fuori le nostre paure e si può forse
ancora peggio c'è scritto non aprile
quindi magari è proprio un genio che
vuole essere liberato lo possa liberare
un lucchetto
riconoscendo che tu sei un motivo o
qualcuno l'ha messa perché non voleva
che qualsiasi cosa ci fosse dentro
venisse liberata oppure molto pericoloso
da lì è semplicemente troppo
fantastico per lasciarlo chiuso qua
dentro e quando poi dovremo aprirlo no
lasciato mi piace sotto a questo video
vi raccomando sì io sono pronto ad
aprirlo e quando meno è meglio non
aprirlo anzi facciamo così loro sono
scorso la sotto al letto e speriamo che
prima o poi scompaia ok chiunque si sia
poi dentisti camera
mi raccomando non toccarlo kay e ora
vado a fare qualche ricerca sui banchi
va bene
alla vita da vita
è un aver paura pone adesso ti libero io
è vero che realizzerà i tutti i miei
desideri tipo quel cibo come la vasta le
torte soprattutto alle torte tante torte
cascate di cioccolato apri apri i
biscotti anche i ricordi
si lo so un attimino che trucchetto non
si apre le zone non forzarlo da qui e
lasciami ei paesi stanno liberando che
succede
domani stupido umano ma io ti stavo per
liberare adesso ti lascio chiusolo ha
detto
mi è cascato
il genio ma che ci sia qua dentro adesso
si sono arrabbiato tantissimo
tu dici io invece penso che magari
liberandolo lui si possa sentire più
libero appunto no piuttosto che stare
chiuso là dentro lasciamolo in pace
[Musica]
ma cos'è successo
che cosa hai fatto qua stavo provando a
scassinarla hai rovinato ho rovinato il
baule ho fatto solo dei piccoli segni
siano o no ora ci potrebbe essere una
maledizione che si staglia su di noi
cosa che era un baule o qualsiasi cosa
con te e con tieni
brucia
no non ha un progetto da un
peccato perché tutti mi amerà tv
dobbiamo trovare la svolta al libro ecco
tutto qualcosa lì per terra la chiave
non ci credi la chiamerà dentro al libro
tutto questo tempo era il libro avrà una
bravo però state bruciate aspettiamo che
si raffreddi aspetta tempi libero
facciamo così proviamo cosa ci vediamo
speriamo che funzioni
si
ok piano piano zero dobbiamo prima nere
pronti e attenti vi ricordate quando ho
aperto la scatola che sono usciti cui
mostri venivo che non esca un mostro
anche da qua dentro
cosa perché no non volte lo abbiamo
forza riproviamo
aggiunge la luce ma certo è un baule un
bowl antico sarà stato tantissimi anni
al buio quindi forse è meglio se
chiudiamo le tende così a meno che non
ha subito la tempo europeo bravi in
questo chiusi si chiude ancora possiamo
aprirlo si ok ragazzi siamo pronti ad
aprire paura finalmente aperto abbiamo
fatto voi siamo prontissimi poi se non
avete ancora lasciato mi piace lo
sciopero non è solo passato prima di
aprire paura e pensate mi piace volevo
che pronti
sì
fino a quanto sò prima cosa libero chi
il baule tagliate le mappe so dice mani
di dosso cosa ha paura ma notizie ma di
signor baule stupido ma certo mi rubano
no paura ma che vuoi da me detta così è
che non vedono male una delle creature
ve lo avevo detto però non trattenuto
una portentosa lui è un po maleducato
roccia
che puzza penso che abbia mangiato
qualcosa di morto diversi diversi mesi
fa
ei ma cosa ce l'ha dentro il rischo
vedere qualcosa di rosso di umani
sa i miei produttori della forza meglio
se rimettiamo il lucchetto e lo
richiudiamo e poi lo buttiamo da non
potè ottima idea allora dài chiediamolo
subito vi diamo subito così al piano non
si lamenta più davvero avesse un
occhietto rilasciato
proprio aspetto
una maledizione
edizione è ok meglio non richiuderlo
allora
lasciamolo così lontana terminare mai
domo vederti creatura c'è dentro e
vedere se riusciamo a catturarla con
libro ci hai ragione e come facciamo
però se lui non si vuole far avvicinare
da noi
frati sentivo io l'ho tempo fermo e tu
lo giudico nel lucchetto va bene e poi
ce ne sbarazziamo non ho detto che
lancera una maledizione
ok va bene proviamo partiti
ma sono andato il baule avete visto tu
l'hai visto non mi dire che ce l'abbiamo
fatto scappare cos'è una poltrona
cotrollo
si è spostato qui come fate ad arrivare
qua ci sono ancora la creatura dentro
signor baule
casa i
ma non si fa così paura ea cavallo in
tutti un hotel chi ci sta pure riuscendo
questa puzza testo chiudiamolo ok ma da
chiederlo io
ma
schiacciarci le dita e ha detto che gli
dà fastidio la luce del sole
sembra che si è fermato ma che già da
tempo di studiare è
regista
e paure
che facciamo non è che l'abbiamo fatto
fuori poverini
sia baule
alla luce va bene va bene riportatemi
dentro e io mi aprirò
cosa
si aspetta ma possiamo fidarci secondo
voi dobbiamo fidarci di questo baule
parte non dobbiamo fidarci lo dobbiamo
lasciare poi il sole ma non scopriremo
mai cosa c'è dentro così io voglio
sapere se c'è un genio all'interno non
c'è un genio dai prezzi
non si muove più 20 che vola ci avevo
riportato dentro casa adesso artina
rivela i suoi segreti
insomma per gli hanno insegnato che
prima di starnutire lo ha messo una mano
abbia giustamente tu non c'è una mano
avete un pezzo di legno da martin o
allontanati allontanati proprio ad
aprirlo che magari e tu mi fai
antipatico non lo so smartsys ok baule
sono io sono a vita apriti e rivela i
suoi segreti
metti la faccia ve lo prometto che
rappresenti avessimo riportato in camera
al buio differente aperto avresti
mostrato la creatura all'interno o
qualsiasi cosa cipria e ora inizia
starhotels in faccia basta mi sono
stancata di queste paure richiudiamo lo
con lucchetto lotteria molo presto si
finalmente tutte le chiavi voglio adesso
così no forse è meglio di no è un po
estrema questa cosa e dove lo mettiamo
dove lo mettiamo dove
forse è meglio non so se andiamo quello
parlano sotterriamo entrati dal giardino
guarda diciamo ora di pranzo io dovrei
preparare da mangiare qualcosa no vitale
sempre il solito e va bene andiamo
prigione mazzini tanto un baule che sono
molti anni sara li aspetterà un
pochettino di più cantati soul il
lucchetto quindi io so c'è da stare
tranquilli che cosa preparare
ho dimenticato il libro
eccolo qua
e lucchetto la chiave sarà vitale forse
la creatura che stava dentro il baule si
è liberata da sola vediamo
[Musica]
o no ecco perché mi ha dato
la finestra ma vedrete un resto
il sito è uscito dalla finestra
si è mancato veramente poco
che è successo
marino aiutami aiutami
che schifo
vino dalle linee aquam a
berlino
per le avevo capito che posso per la
creatura la tua cercarmi giardino io
posso guarda non si muove proviamo a
prenderlo dalla sua che effetti
presto per mio aiutami
bravissimo è posto il mio aiutante più
bravo ma non ci arriviamo mannaggia non
ci arriviamo là sopra come facciamo
prenderlo merlino proprio ai fugazi
presta marina prendiamo dei pupazzi
qualcosa tirargli addosso
o no si è spostato dov'è guardatevi
anche voi intorno lo vedete lo vedete da
qualche parte
valentia the book ortona sopra ora non
riuscirò mai più a recuperarlo dalla
sopra come proprio
devo chiamare evitare altri di euro
prendono dall'italia d'italia l'idea del
freddo brigati
sta per capire credo e tutti arriva al
tiro mi fa schifo del vino prendilo su
no non si scherza poi de moliner
rimettiamolo dentro don ok così
scomparirà per sempre spento ecco qua
dai piccolino vai pubbliche 6 liberatevi
sempre qua sotto non aver paura di me
stai e di pure si mirino il bravo tiene
anche turbone fermo così lo cattureremo
che da vivo il violino
[Musica]
non marino non posso non posso pure la
scatola che so che tu vorresti annusarle
capire che cos'è e forse creano chiama
ma non poi è pericolosissima ok il
lucchetto mi mancava il lucchetto dove
lo metto dove lo metto chiediamo la
festa
non deve uscire mai più da qua scampato
pericolo ora sotterriamo il baule così
non lo rivedremo mai più ok
se meglio se dormo un pochettino
buonanotte berlino
e anita ecco che cosa è successo ho
sentito dei rumori che i rumori mi
ricordo che è successo qualcosa col
baule ma c'era qualcosa nel baule brutto
qualcosa nel baule ma mi sento un po
strana già stati ci arriva nyt ha preso
qualcosa nel baule che hai preso è
volato dalla finestra si vabbè dai
allora magari riusciamo un attimo fuori
prendi una boccata d'aria
magari ti fa stare meglio ok andiamo dai
bar che dobbiamo si sentì che bellavia
fresco il famoso adesso ci piacerebbe si
sta
sfaldando
ho bisogno di stare un momento da stormo
che eri tu vai a mangiare ci vediamo
dopo
ok
vi siete accorti che c'è qualcosa di
strano e sento strana ho paura che sia
stato colpi strano così d'acqua casomai
vitale sta ora egli andò alla porta
credo che col pipistrello che ho
catturato nel baule abbiamo fatto
qualcosa forse dovrei riaprire il
pipistrello no è troppo pericoloso
meglio consultare il libro storie
paurose guardiamo una delle schede
creature ma voi ce l'avete è ora
disponibile in tutte le librerie online
andati a prenderlo e ora vediamo se
troviamo qualche informazione il vampiro
il vampiro può assumere altre forme come
la forma di un pipistrello
devo trovare un antidoto una soluzione
prima di trasformarmi del tutto e semi
invece alla luce del sole forse
succederà qualcosa
[Musica]
mi sta trasformando allora come faccio
devo assolutamente nascondere i denti
abitare non deve vederli quando avrò
finito di trasformarli per un pericolo
per lui devo fare qualcosa devo trovare
una soluzione presto il libro
[Musica]
no no lo di stramaccioni proprio niente
io non mi sento molto bene ha ancora non
ti senti bene
no no non mi sento per niente doria anzi
penso di avere una forma di influenza tu
per contagio vada quindi immediate ti
allontana il più possibile influenza
super contagiosi allontanati ai voto si
articola il naso
entrambi
pure tutti rete stanno dire come il
baule si sia stato il pau le porte a
contagiarvi ma è importante che tu te ne
vai dire lontano possibile bocchetti
punto qualcosa di caldo magari minuti no
grazie
anzi cosa c'è per pranzo lato posto
preferito agli occhi più principiano
casa che però oggi in un pranzo
ottimo allora io posso mangiare i due
piatti il mio il tuo patetico il
probabile parola o che non vedo l'ora ha
tolto soprattutto riguardo di un po così
magari ti passa c'è bisogno di una
tisana gamba aiuta lo porto si aspetta
momento farmi controllare il baule mai
che c'avete le fare andando ma io ancora
non buon nell'acqua della pasta io
potrei contagiati
vado via
c'è mancato poco e ora come fa sapere
allora nascosta vitale tv bloccare la
trasformazione troviamo una soluzione
insieme
vita
imita
mamma mia perché si è arrabbiata per
qualcosa di sarah ti hanno detto di
lasciarmi
solo portato una tisana così a magari ti
riprendi ti aiuta un pochettino con la
tosse
con quale tosse prima levi la tosse
starnuti vi avevi freddo tutto anche
portato la tisana così va bene lascia in
pace devo parlare con il mio 4 ore
tuo padrone ma cosa stai dicendo stai
parlando ste bisbigliando al baule
si è il proprio renziani cioè ho ragione
io che stai bisbigliando al baule non
capisco
atleta che brucia
non sono da nessuna parte prego
accomodati pure
ok ma come mai sei cambiata così tanto
prima volevo rimanere da sola adesso mi
sento molto meglio
ti senti molto meglio se un po
inquietante perché non lo so mister mi
stai fissato quegli occhi giganti per
allontanare la tazza di tisana calda
come del mio padrone vuole parlarti mio
padrone sì ho visto che vedi passare
dalla grande ma perché c'è questo che
stai facendo
marino sono usciti fuori questi da
bambino
questa volta riesca
ma la prossima volta diventerà un
banchino come me vero padrone
[Musica]
questo ti libere quando prost ancora
abbastanza parte di libererò molto
presto
nascondiamo ci nascondiamo ci riescono
qui avete visto aveva coi denti
lunghissimi si stanno trasformando che
adesso che cosa faccio aspetta aspetta
vita mette csc pensarci perché la scheda
creatura vi ricorda qualcosa bravo un
bambino quindi la scheda da creature dei
vampiri nel libro storie paurose ho
letto che l'aglio può aiutare a tenere
lontano i vampiri forse è meglio se vado
a prendere dell'aglio ora che ci penso
magari che posso mangiare un pezzo così
sono ancora al sicuro qui nel
nascondiglio
ho preso dell'aglio stavo pensando che
magari questo però conservo per dopo per
tirarmi addosso ogni caso caso dovesse
servire e questo mangiamolo ci siamo il
mio piano è entrare in camera prendere
il baule perché ha detto che all'interno
c'è una creatura e poi prendere anche il
libro in modo tale che con il libro
posso catturare la creatura
del sangue
senatore di tango in
[Musica]
salita si tornata per farti morte sì
certo come no anzi ti dirò di più ho
portato anche alla mano
magari sono più che piano di agno pensa
tiro di aglio guarda ti dirò di più
questo lo prendo io
lascia guarda sono stati rosolare
l'aglio ha funzionato scappiamo
fieri di questo è tanto
che la lascia così esiste poligolfo
ecco ci sono riuscito a sottrarre il
baule sanità non c'è orecchio come sono
riuscito a farlo probabilmente mai mi
hanno aiutato tantissimo e o anche il
libro il libro storie paurose e voi ce
l'avete ma adesso cerchiamo subito la
chiave non trovata e qui con la chiave
possa aprire le paure
[Musica]
o no
farina ha riferito verità è scappato il
pipistrello da paula a vista o no vita
si può spiegare una cosa sì
che cosa è successo
ritornato
no ti spiego in quel tempo c'era già
venduti ristretto
ascoltami il pipistrello da morsa inizia
trasformato in un bambino capisce devo
trovare il libro per catturare il
pipistrello così tu ti potrei inserirmi
trasformare in verità dove andate il
pipistrello e si è sbattuto da qualche
parte in camera non lo so devo cercarlo
subito ma no non dobbiamo salvare il
pipistrello dobbiamo prendere libro
catturare il pipistrello è il libro
allontano ludom e allontana la partita
con ascoltami tu non stai ragionando in
questo momento tu sei un bambino
aspetta a dobbiamo catturarlo il
pipistrello
che stai facendo sì che mi vorrei
mordere berlino ma ascolta se invece è
semplice pochissimo fuori al sole
ecco gli eventi non lo avrò qui davanti
a te perché altrimenti zincatura io
invece convoglio catturare te voglio
catturare i primi stallo capisce
che cosa c'è da ritenere di davvero che
correndo si offrono un pipistrello
sì l'ho creato davvero vogliamo come un
pipistrello
cercavo di attaccarmi comunque distretto
per ottenere quello non è un pipistrello
quello e
st trova ti
viene ma che cosa
sono troppo lo
scafo siamo mio padrone trappola ti ho
portato una vittima da mordere quindi
qui anche allora era già uscito dal
baule ovunque giusti a
dragona ok
[Musica]
chi chi chi è quello
scusi lei chi ha fatto entrare qua
non sapere che devo io e non era
questo
dracula re dei vampiri questo umano è
pronto per essere morso e per essere
trasformato in uno di noi ma prima devo
assicurarmi di una cosa aspetta
ei
no
che paura all'inter che avrei preso il
libro ora non hai più nulla da temere
mio padrone anzi
sono l'amore di dolore ora non potrai
catturare trappola e neanche me dentro
al libro a storie paurose e come faccio
verso
beh ti dico io ho una soluzione quale
sarebbe questa soluzione le tue unica
soluzione
per salvarti e
unirsi a noi
dovrei diventare un vampiro come noi
altrimenti altrimenti non hai scampo
quindi che cosa
scegliere avrei un attimo un impegno all
importante pranzo di lavoro
vi prometto che tornerò tornerò si si
come no certo che tornerò da voi
aiuto già
stupido umano attento tornerà tornerà da
noi perché la sua unica soluzione vero
dobbiamo trasformarlo anzi dobbiamo
creare il nostro esercito di vampiri
trasformare più mani possibili e vampiri
e voi volete diventare un vampiro come
noi
iniziamo con l'umano e poi piano piano
guarderemo tante altre persone
finalmente i vampiri domineranno il
mondo non gli umani ma e va bene
sono molto contenta che ti piace il mio
piano padrone dracula ma ora che cosa
facciamo
lo aspettiamo andiamo a prenderlo
abbiamo bisogno di cibo se no ci
indeboliremo sempre più e vero dobbiamo
nutrirci di tempo altrimenti piano piano
non riusciremo più a morte dovremmo
dormire nelle bare tutto il giorno
quindi aspettiamo che torni pure l'umano
tanto sarà molto facile morderlo credo e
poi ora noi abbiamo il libro e lui non
potrà catturarci
ho un piano proverò farle uscire acqua
fuori così con la luce del sole si
indeboliranno venite schiappe
li devi darmi il sole insieme a me
scendo là fuori l'umano
provato a prendermi adesso provateci voi
che usciamo da fuori ma c'è troppa luce
cioè troppo sole uffa non sta
funzionando
forse devo ballare meglio
crede davvero che cadremo nella sua
misera trappola
noi offriamo vai là fuori non sta
funzionando neanche il balletto proverò
a fare l'imitazione di dracula e vediamo
se così si arrabbierà di più e verrà qua
fuori dracula dracula il più grande
bambino del mondo
dracula
stupido umano
questo è un rombo non ti preoccupare
dracula vedrai che tornerà qua e a quel
punto dobbiamo morder rosso vita
dici di essere un pipistrello papadopoli
sempre una gallina
[Risate]
aiutami marino il piano non ha
funzionato
che cosa possiamo fare tim e parla
chiamare aiuto che posso chiamare
ex il lupo aveva detto che in qualsiasi
momento lo potevamo chiamare in caso di
grande aiuto o di urgenza come gara
dovevamo chiamare bussare a tre volte
sul no però il libro aspetta aveva detto
che in caso d'urgenza potevo ululare che
urlando lui sarebbe comparso bellino
proviamo ad ululare insieme vediamo se
arriva
l'ex
è successo un casino che non c'è è
successo è successo che la vita si è
trasformato in vampiro ventina con un
altro bambino cioè no aspetta ed irap un
trappola contratto granulari
praticamente vogliono trasformarmi
vogliono trasformando in un bottino si
no ascolta ho bisogno del tuo aiuto come
posso fare per
fermare questa cosa è far ritornare
anita com'era prima allora allora
partiamo dal fatto che non è un bambino
comune non è un bambino comune quello è
tra una il signore dei vampiri the molto
grave questo è gravissimo e gravissimo e
adesso come posso fare
ma quindi ti sei fatto scappare il
pipistrello dame paure e come diceva il
baule ma non sapevo ci posso pipistrello
dentro 20 quando ho aperto
il sito via non sono riuscito a fare
berlina 100 certo dovevo immaginarmelo
l'unico modo che abbiamo adesso se siete
scorso dire è quello di ricordarci le
informazioni sui bambini nel libro
storie paurose
ricordarci è ad esempio mi ricordo dalla
schiena tra vampiri che chi viene morso
viene trasformato in vampiro no non devo
essere morto non devo essere morto sai è
arrivato un momento o bracciali
abbracciare perché non mi piaceva quello
che ti sto per dire non piacerà tanto io
mediato
dai aiutami aspetta io ho detto già
aiutando ti do l'informazione chiave
l'affare l'informazione chiave devi
prendere il libro è solo con il libro
che potrai catturare il signore dei
bambini e sconfiggendo lowe in tutti gli
altri torneranno mai la vittoria sarà
tua mi sa che ho in mente un'idea su
come convincerli
magari posso dire che voglio unirmi a
loro e così posso ma che farà abbassare
la loro guardia nel frattempo
sgattaiolare ea rubare il libro che ne
pensi questo è un piano geniale bene
adesso che hai tutte le informazioni che
io ti ho dato io posso tornare a
fare le mie cose sai sono molto
impegnato io come lupo e aiuto tutti
bene immagini alex beh io nel frattempo
ti ringrazio vediamo allora divertiti
lex ciao amico ciao
ciao ragazzi stavo un attimo ripensando
alla vostra offerta vi ricordate di
unirmi a voi
già funziona e noi l'abbiamo piano piano
però prendiamone un attimo ma parliamo
che prima sono tenuto del parlarne
sicuramente avete ragione è una delle
mie poche speranze chance chiamiamolo
come vogliamo
sì sì sì sì certo che sì sarà
un secondo momento ne è andato un po di
tempo per riflettere e non c'è tempo il
nostro piano deve andare o buona
attenzione attenzione invece merlino che
lui verrà trasformato un giorno aspetta
un attimo però mi è venuta un'idea
aleggia già i canini quindi siamo già
avvantaggiati vedete già già possono
formare un piccolo esercito di quattro
con me e merlino e siamo già contagiati
con i canini basta perdere tempo ma di
cosa sta parlando questo brano
trasformalo
pronta sì sì sì sì sono venuto qui
apposta per essere trasformato però
aspettate un attimo parliamo in un
secondo che tutta questa per entrare
aspettato un attimo ci parliamo secondo
io nel frattempo e avevo studiato nel
frattempo è ad esempio so benissimo che
ai bambini ai fantini ad esempio non
piace l'angolo che schifo l'ha
chiarito pesante ruota da da lasciarti
stecchito poi nel frattempo ho scoperto
anche che per esempio alle volte avete
bisogno di portare alle persone perché
dal morso delle persone dal morso delle
persone come dire come dire come dire
[Musica]
non è vero
note la buona fattura ed evocato la roux
che catturino e cantore noi una
risposta di metà squadra stati spostati
vita sposta vino devo catturare lui dai
togliti togliti subito tempo togliti
no no
[Musica]
no non è partito il raggio dal libro
quindi vuol dire per un nome cattura
ho visto la testa non scapperà questa
volta
sono riuscito a prenderlo chiamo
brancolare sei riuscito a scappare
questa volta ti ho chiuso la finestra
[Risate]
ehi ma trovato un attimo non ho capito
il gioco che cosa stiamo guardando qui
esattamente
questo è proprio un vampiro
principianti ea spiegare di tutto
qualcosa deve essere andato storto
sì sembra non capire la nostra missione
nome cosa stiamo facendo stiamo
pianificando
la conquista del mondo
dobbiamo trasformare tutta l'umanità
vampiri noi dobbiamo
conquistare il mondo
giovane discepoli
noi siamo qui adesso inizieremo nelle
città vicine a mettere i nostri primi
alleati
e trasformeremo i pericoli non piedi
proprio come te sì sì sperando prima
trasformazione funzioni di perfezione
eravamo anche un po meglio rispetto alla
tv si
sbatte le ali c'è qualcosa di strano e
mio padrone dracula mi dispiace ho
effettuato io questa trasformazione ma
non so che cosa sia andato storto ma può
essere che il problema non sia la
trasformazione ma il problema sia
soltanto lui non mi è mai capitato in
miliardi di anni
ma potrebbe anche essere in effetti non
era molto normale neanche prima
hai ragione scusate non ho capito chi è
grande e radicale
ma lascia stare continuiamo con il piano
della birra conquista pp dubbio ma mi
devo si contento che tra poco border hai
anche tu il tuo primo umana la
trasformerà in un vampiro
si celi o non lo so io che tiro più
legato al cibo al cibo quello normale
diciamo tipo la pasta stadio fiorentino
o no o no però lo posso ma se lo fa
stare
male io voglio continuare la pasta
branzino voglio vedere meglio voglio
mettere tutta tutto più quanto tutto
tutta promosso a 1 mamma mia che paura
e tipo
qualcosa di male bruce ketta dall'aglio
vuole perché per l'angelo che posso dire
è che io non lo sopporto più ce ne
sbarazziamo va bene per farlo voi vi
prego in cosa potremmo trasformarlo
in
in un candelabro
che cosa stanno dicendo io non voglio
essere un candelabro
collaboro collaboro di youtube può
costare il mondo adesso anzi vi dico il
mio piano siete d'accordo intanto siamo
allora secondo me inizia avuto questa
parte tutta questa bella palude verde
perché secondo me qui c'è più cillo
partendo da qui possiamo espandersi non
può andare più verso nord più per
fermare i laghi le montagne poiché ne so
magari non molto in montagna possiamo
prendere un po di sole li scendere giù
al mare e prendere un altro posizione
anche lì al mare per cercare di
conquistare
e tutta la meraviglia del mondo che
pensate mi piace come piano è poi
ovviamente ci possiamo fermare per
mangiare in tutti i posti che visitiamo
tipo assaggiare tutti gli atti locali
man mano che ci spostiamo che ne pensate
siete d'accordo
l'unica cosa che dovrai mangiare sangue
umano
però io preferirei mostra un bel panino
per fare un bel piatto di spaghetti che
giri di origini e poi ricattato e che
resa una pasta un pochettino più
più densa rispetto al fango in mano se
voi lo elimino subito no con ida
migliori potremo usarlo come esca
per adescare degli altri umani si certo
hai capito bene come esca escan e senza
prego esca nei lavori della porta quello
nuovo
continuiamo il nostro piano di
espanderci e conquistare il mondo e voi
vorreste essere dei vampiri o minore
avete lasciato un mi piace qui sotto
dobbiamo sempre muoverci di notte di
notte che stai dicendo io di notte dormo
almeno ho fatto un paio di correggio di
nota alle dieci e mezzo dialetto come si
fa a di notte si dorme di giorno si
mangia lo sanno tutti
di giorno ma che dici tu perdendo la
pazienza pur permettono farlo arrabbiare
vero hai ragione tra cola non ce la
faccio più neanche i radi torna più
vanta di notte più bar me
basta non ne posso più
allieva mia presidente fai un training
ma questo
giovane vampiro non troppo colpire fai
un training veloce da vampiro si mio
padrone provvedo subito iniziano con le
basi
moriero non basta il morso il volo è
giusto iniziamo con il morso da vampiro
dai su sbrigati slegati principiante
mesi di là si tratta di parole qualcosa
allora lezione numero uno di errore un
vampiro di diventare un vero vampiro
devi imparare a mordere con iter e
carini io sono proprio border bordo del
panino mandateli mordere il collo per
far diventare le altre persone vampiri
ad esempio se questo è il collo di una
persona devi fare così
ok posso provarci anch'io a spina
cosa posso fare ecco ecco ecco cosa da
una zucca
cosa sta facendo
ma che stai facendo questo non sembra il
collo di una persona effettivamente un
pochino croccante pronto non riuscito a
far segno qui non lo fosse non riuscirà
a trasformare in un bottino non riuscirò
mai a diventare un vero vampiro
prima prova
ok seconda prova fondamentale
dell'essere banchina trasformarsi in
pipistrelli e il volare pronti stai bene
attento 3 2 1
facile no basta fare 3 2 1
che è successo favolando dopo l'anno no
mibac e non sto volando ci riprova a
separarci veloce però ora due è
[Musica]
scappato qualcosa mi fa
volevo ormai una rete tutte le prove
aiuto
quando ci siamo
troppo umiliante
da bambino mi ha chiamato possibili
che cosa vuole perché chi sta guardando
così strali dimmi dimmi fitti sì sì sì
sì
il bambino vuole rovinare i nostri piani
il popolo è stato buono è stato bravo
allora dicevamo come conquistare
quest'area del
ma cosa sta facendo il cane
al baule che contiene il libro
furukawa no
no ho preso il libro nero fare cose
novecento
no
wow è scomposto il conte dracula
che cosa è successo
il libro vitale
tornati normali e di
questo gioiellino riesco un valore viene
adesso il libro il libro è stato berlino
equilibro ecco libro berlino da barbato
silvino preso il libro dal baule ha
catturato dracula aspetto va così e
tutto questo buio a cedere un po di
luciano vero non siamo più ampi
guarda l'ex ex
certo a catturare anche
lo sapevo che potevo contare su di voi
lo sapevo grazie anche al suo aiuto l'ex
sei stato bravissimo darci tutte quelle
informazioni che berlino
quindi abbiamo finito tutta la challenge
abbiamo catturato tutte le creature di
storie paurose no no non è un ex non mi
dispiace dirvelo ragazzi però ancora
ancora non è finita ma come no l'ex no
chi è rimasto ancora mi dispiace dovervi
dire questo ma mancano ancora
due creature quali sono queste due
creature ragazzi per scoprire le altre
due creature dovete leggere il libro di
storie paurose le trovate qui se non ce
l'avete ancora andato a prenderlo beh è
arrivata l'ora di andare ragazzi questo
lo lascio a voi è il buone mani ci
vediamo io degli impegni ricordatevi che
ci avete bisogno di me basta chiamarmi
ciao ciao i ragazzi come ha detto l'ex
trovate storie paurose a scuola di
misteri in tutte le librerie online non
potete non averlo coprirete un sacco di
cose qua dentro fatemi sapere nikon 23
ce lo avete e ora ci vediamo alla
prossima avventura ciao ciao oggi
occorre subito a leggerlo tutto